اين كانت اقصى الضربات للمعسكر
الديمقراطيه تحديدا اهمل الحزب او ضمن
ربما ولاء ولايه نيويورك لتاريخها
الليبرالي فلم يصب تركيزه عليها لتاتي
الضربه الاقوى منها
الحصن الديمقراطي المنيع نيويورك قلبت
الطاوله على حزبها واهداف الجمهوريين
اربعه مقاعد في الكونجرس وهو اكبر عدد من
المقاعد يخسرها الديمقراطيون في اي ولايه
على الاطلاق عبر الترويجي لمخاوف زياده
التضخم وانتشار الجريمه تغلغل الجمهوريون
وكسبوا اصواتا الناخبين في ضواحي ايلاند
بسهوله النائب ديمقراطي توماس قال ان
تجاهل مخاوف الناخبين المتعلقه بالسلامه
هو سياسه عامه سيئه ادت الى خسائر متعدده
كان يمكن تجنبها
واضاف ان هذه الخسائر سيكون لها تاثير
سلبي للغايه ليس فقط على نيويورك ولكن على
ميزان القوه في البلاد حصد الجمهوريون اذا
جائزه مذهله هزيمه النائب شون
باتريكمالوني رئيس حمله الديمقراطيين في
مجلس النواب المكلف بحمايه سيطره حزبه على
الكونجرس لكن ما حدث والذي هز قبضه
الديمقراطيين فعلا لم يؤثر على منصب
الحاكم الذي فازت به كافي هوكول بفارق خمس
نقاط على النائب الجمهوري لي زالدن
المدعوم ترامب تنقل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
عن هاورد احد الاستراتيجيين الديمقراطيين
البرازيين قوله ملخصا خيبه امل الحسبه لقد
كانت ليله مروعه في نيويورك من سيتحكم في
الكونغرس تشير نتائج الى ان مجلس النواب
يميل نحو الجمهوريين لكن الامر لم يحسن
بعد اذ يمكن ان تساعد بطاقات الاقتراع
البريديه المتاخره الديمقراطيين اكثر لكن
سيستغرق ذلك عده ايام اما مجلس الشيوخ
فستحتدم المعركه في ثلاث ولايات هي نيفادا
وجورجيا وارينا فرز الاصوات المعلقه في
نيفادا واريزونا قد يستغرق اياما ايضا لكن
السيطره ستحسمها جورجيا التي تتجه الى
جوله الاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر المقبل
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير
صحيح ان الجمهوريين كسبوا في نيويورك
لكنهم خسروا في كثير من الولايات السبب
ترامب ومرشحوها او هكذا يرى على الاقل
انصار وقادت الحزب الذين وجهوا سيلا من
الانتقادات والاتهامات للرئيس السابق
الرئيس الخامس والاربعون بات تحت النار
داخل حسبه تنقل صحيفه نيويورك عن ديفيد
اوربان مستشار ترامب السابق قوله ان
الجمهوريين اتبعوا دونالد ترامب الذي
اوصلهم الى حافه الهاويه ينظر الى ترامب
الى حد بعيد على انه المسؤول عن النهايه
المخيبه للجمهوريين في انتخابات الثلاثاء
اذ هزم عدد كبير من المرشحين الذين ادهم
بمن في ذلك المرشحون لمنصب الحاكم ومجلس
الشيوخ في ولايه بنسلفانيا وحكام ولايه
مشجن ونيويورك
منذ فتره طويله قال انه لا ينبغي ان يكون
ترامب وجه الحزب الجمهوري في 20 24 مضيفا
ان الحسبه لا يمكن ان يتمحور حول فرد واحد
[موسيقى]
في كل الاحوال كشف الهجوم اللاذق على
الرئيس السابق عبر قناه فوكس وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعيه ان ترامب في اضعف في
نقطه له من الناحيه السياسيه منذ هجوم
السادس من يناير 20 21 على مبنى الكابل
بعض قاده الحزب اللومي عليه تحديدا
لتاييده محمد اوز ومؤخرا ترددت انباء عن
ان ترامب وبخ مستشاريه لانهم دفعوه لتاييد
الرجل
السابق قال على قناه اي بي سي ان ترامب
اظهر مره اخرى ان اختياراته السياسيه لا
تتعلق بالحزب ولا تتعلق بالبلد بل تتعلق
به شخصيا او بالاحرى بمصالحه الخاصه
الامر يتطور فقط
المستشار السابق
زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ ان
يكون الرانده حاكم فلوريدا او لنكن
فلاين عن ترامب في انتخابات 20 و24 بينما
قالت كيلي ما كناني يا سكرتاريه صحفيه
السابقه للبيت الابيض في اداره ترامب على
قناه فوكس نيوز ان رئيسها السابق يجب ان
يتاخر عن الاعلان الذي تحدث عنه والمفترض
يوم الخامس عشر من نوفمبر وعليه الانتظار
الى حين يحسن نتائج ولايه جورجيا التي
تشهد لاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر كما قلنا
اذا يرى بعض الجمهوريين ان ترامب قوض فرص
الحزب في الانتخابات النصفيه وكان السبب
الرئيس في منع حدوث فيما جرى ما جرى
الترويج له من قدوم الموجه الحمراء